роки Міністерство проводило достатньо
великі я б навіть сказав масової
підсумкові колеги запрошуючи на них від
600 до понад тисячі учасників це себе
абсолютно виправдовувало оскільки
створювало живе інформаційне поле в
цьому році Міністерство вирішило піти
трохи іншим шляхом в залі Зараз
присутньо разом з членами колеги трохи
більше 200 освітян але до підготовки
цього засідання ми залучили найближчу до
школи а відповідної саму важливу та
масову Ланку району в межах і в
масштабах всеукраїнської акції нові
стандарти нова школа понад чотири з
половиною тисячі освітян виїжджали в
інші райони міста вивчати досвід а
приймали їх понад 20 тисяч колег з інших
регіонів з кожного району з кожного
міста і території міністерства отримали
відповідну інформацію і надзвичайно
цікаві пропозиції Таким чином ми можемо
говорити що в підготовці інформації І
підготовці підсумкової колеги
по суті взяло участь близько 25 тисяч
провідних фахівців освіти нашої країни
Вони готували і матеріали інформаційні і
пропозиції до цієї колеги друга
особливість Крим загальної інформації
про готовність навчальних закладів до
початку навчального року від дитячого
садочка до університету колегія також
розгляне конкретні питання про
готовність початкової школи до роботи по
новим державним стандартам Це зумовлено
безумовно тим що ми починаємо працювати
по ним з першого вересня
приїхав особливості та перспективи
сказано та написано вже достатньо
головне завдання забезпечити
впровадження
стандартів і врахувати можливі
складності в цьому процесі
запевняючи Міністерство організувало
масштабну підготовчу роботу та має
найповнішу інформацію про стан на місцях
який ми сьогодні і обговоримо питання
Підготовки до нового навчального року
розглядав на своєму окремому засіданні
15 серпня Кабінет Міністрів України за
результатами засідання керівництвом
уряду було дано відповідні доручення
спрямовані на покращення функціонування
загальної середньої та дошкільної освіти
і нам приємно відзначити що така увага з
боку Кабінету Міністрів до освітянських
проблем є найкращим свідченням
пріоритетності в діяльності уряду всієї
нашої галузі хотів би ще одне
підкреслити
нам не вдасться уникнути Цієї осені
впливу розпочати політичної компанії і
тому всім освітянам не лише присутнім В
цьому залі слід бути готовими до того що
на абсолютний біле будуть говорити не
лише сіре а й навіть чорне тому що
мінімізувати перекручення та з метою
оперативного об'єктивно інформування
педагогічних працівників громадськості я
пропонував розмістити на сайтах всіх
навчальних закладів управління освітою
банер сайту Міністерства і
використовувати також стрічку новин
освітнього порталу освітянського
педагогічна преса та максимально
використовувати всі інші інформаційні
можливості Я маю на увазі інформаційні
портали в обласних управління освіти і
науки Міністерства освіти і науки молоді
та спорту Автономної Республіки Крим
сьогоднішнє засідання яке вже казав ми
будемо
поділимо на частини в першій інформації
про стан готовність а в другій частині
будемо говорити про старт нової
початкової нової початкової школи
крім того є ще два питання про які ми
говорили ми їх розглянемо в робочому
порядку якщо немає заперечень то давайте
будемо переходити до розгляду першого
питання
Дозвольте мені особисто інформувати вас
про готовність навчальних закладів до
початку нового навчального року
Шановні колеги як я вже казав 15 серпня
відбулось засідання Кабінету Міністрів
де було розглянуто всю динаміку стану
готовності навчальних закладів до нового
навчального року коротко зупинюсь лише
на основних показниках
дошкільна освіта мережа дошкільних
навчальних закладів невпинно зростає і
це позитив на сьогодні кількість дитячих
садків складає
16277 І мені приємно відзначити що це
наші 650 більше ніж в червні 2010 року
коли ми проголосили відновлення дитячих
садків пріоритетною сферою в діяльності
всіх ланок освіти з них лише в першому
півріччі 2012 року в країні відкрито 199
нових дошкільних закладів Це сім
новобудов 43 садочки відновили свою
діяльність
149 дошкільних навчальних закладів
відкрито в пристосованих приміщеннях
приємно що змінюється і зовнішній вигляд
дитячих садків перед вами окремі дитячі
садки які відкрилися наприкінці Минулого
року завдяки розширенню мережі кількість
дітей які здобувають дошкільну освіту в
дитячих закладах дошкільних досягла в
країні понад 1 млн 385 000 це
171,5 тисячі більше ніж в період коли ми
починали цю роботу за рекомендаціями
міністерства в регіонах запроваджуються
різні форми залучення малюків до
здобуття дошкільної освіти завдяки цьому
відсоток охоплення дітей від трьох до
шести років в серпні поточного року
складає по країні
86%. що повністю відповідає не лише
європейським показникам а рекомендаціям
Європейського Союзу для країн-членів
Європейського Союзу Слід зазначити що це
відбувається разом з дуже приємною
тенденцією невпинним зростанням
кількості дітей дошкільного віку
завершується забезпечення обов'язкової
дошкільної освіти дітей старшого
дошкільного віку охоплення п'ятирічних
дітей сьогодні в Україні складає
99,8%. а в 19-й регіонах цей показник ще
до п'ятирічок досяг 100%. Тепер можна
говорити головне про якість освіти в
травні поточного року затверджено новий
державний стандарт базовий компонент
дошкільної освіти при його розробленні
вивчено кращий світовий досвід і
проведено надзвичайно широке громадське
обговорення документу після дворічної
апробації схвалено програму розвитку
дітей старшого дошкільного віку програма
впевнений Старт і з 1 вересня цього року
програма стає обов'язковою для усіх
дошкільних навчальних закладів країни
проведено також і перший всеукраїнський
огляд конкурс на кращий архітектурний
проект сучасного дошкільного навчального
закладу краще з цих проектів було
направлено до Міністерства економіки до
мінрегіонбуду до місцевих державних
адміністрацій для використання при
будівництві нових дитячих садків тепер
проблеми одна з них приміщення не
функціонуючих дитячих садків за сухими
даними держстату на їх на сьогодні в
країні 813
цю частину їх на жаль орендують державні
установи на засіданні серпневому
Кабінету Міністрів прем'єр-міністр
України Микола Азаров дав доручення всім
міністерствам державним комітетом і
структурам чиї підрозділи вселилися в
дитячі садки впродовж року звільнити їх
самі обласні управління освіти мусять
знати ці адреси і звернутися до
керівників регіонів та до керівників
Міністерства на сьогодні ще близько 80
тисяч наших громадян очікують на
влаштування дитини до садка найбільше
таких очікуючих близько 14 тисяч в
автономній Республіці Крим в
Хмельницькій області близько 12 000 у
івано-франківській 8 та у Львівській
Понад 6000 Я переконаний що прийшов час
серйозно працювати над соціальним
захистом працівників дошкілля
Міністерство зараз опрацьовує відповідні
пропозиції Я сьогодні мав розмову з
міністром фінансів України ю
володимировичам колобовим і ми
найближчим часом відповідні проекти
рішень уряду передамо До кабінету
міністрів наступне загальна середня
освіта завершується підготовка шкіл до
нового навчального року за новими
оперативними даними роботи практично
завершені те що залишилось не буде
заважати навчально-виховному процесу
принаймні так поінформували 23 серпня на
Всеукраїнський селекторній нараді
керівники регіональних управлінь освіти
і науки та охорони здоров'я
останнім часом в засобах масової
інформації та заявах окремих політичних
діячів звучить стурбованість про нібито
величезну кількість закритих в 2012 році
шкіл для порівняння в 2008 році було
закрито 150 шків в цьому році за
інформацією регіональних управління
освіти 73 школи мова цифр лаконічна А
всі інші умови виглядають непрофесійно
та політично заангажованими водночас
наголошую що жодна школа в країні Не
може бути закритий без згоди місцевої
громади зменшилась майже на 17%, і
кількість шкіл де навчається менше 10
учнів якщо Минулого року їх було 605
зараз трохи більше 500 в 2012 році
місцевими державними адміністраціями
заплановано введення в експлуатацію 40
приміщень середніх шкіл нових Найбільше
це Волинська область станом на 3 серпня
відкриті дві школи найбільшість
більшість нових шкіл Буде відкрита
напередодні навчального року Таким чином
підготовка загальноосвітніх навчальних
закладів до роботи в новому навчальному
році іде чітко відповідно до графіків і
всі
19.700 з лишнім шкіл розпочнуть роботу 1
вересня цього року
вибіркові перевірки державної інспекції
навчальних закладів робочих груп
секретаріату Кабміну та Міністерства
показують що іноді довіряти інформаціям
зміст повній мірі не слід і хотів би
попросити керівників територіальних
органів управління освіти якщо на
початку серпня ви ще можете якось для
звітності перед керівниками регіонів
трохи гратися цифрами то час істини - це
1 вересня і я не заздрив би тим хто
свідомо вдається до маніпуляції цих
хотів би сказати що іноді надходять
запити від народних депутатів які
політичні зробили на жаль свою другою
професією наприклад Найбільше що
проблеми є з вакансіями педагогічних
працівників ще раз наголошую такої
проблеми сьогодні в країні не існує А ті
В кого В трудовій книжці два записи
помічник депутата і депутат Хай краще
вивчають матеріальну частину вакансії
вчителів Слава Богу нема тут вже важливо
Інше питання як влаштуватися на роботу
вчителя це стає надалі складнішим
водночас хочу поінформувати що в 2012
році заробітну плату вчителя
підвищувалась і буде підвищуватись
загалом впродовж року 6 разів в тому
числі і до 1 вересня до початку нового
навчального року за три роки середній
посадовий оклад педагогічних працівників
зріст на 27 відсотків середня заробітна
плата 35 Я розумію що строкатість є в
певних регіонах але вона значною мірою
ще залежить від педагогічного
навантаження в тих регіонах де середній
навантаження по області складає 12-13
годин на тиждень на вчителя зрозуміло що
показники заробітної плати виглядають
набагато більш скромну
в наступному навчальному році в
загальноосвітніх навчальних закладах
країни буде впроваджуватись курс за
вибором для учнів 8 чи 9-го 10-го по
11-го класів корисні навички ідея
впровадження курсу ґрунтується на
кращому педагогічному досвіді вже
близько 10 років в школах міста Києва
практикується факультативний курс
Київський вальс головне - це бажання
дітей при кожному курсі корисні навички
можливості вчителів та активність
батьківської громади оцінювання буде
здійснюватись за заліковою системою і не
буде впливати на середній бал шкільного
атестату для найменших школярів тривають
по всій країні заходи всеукраїнської
акції Дай руку першокласник матеріали по
якій будуть узагальнені після 1 вересня
та в повному обсязі по всім регіонам
надані регіональним органом управління
освіти продовжується також підготовка
загальноосвітніх навчальних закладів до
осінньо-зимового сезону станом на 20
моделі понад 90% шкіл завершили ремонт
котелень на 94% ремонт системи опалення
та завезено 62% від потреби твердого
палива на опалювальний сезон по кожному
закладу є графік і роботи будуть
завершені до 15 жовтня
проблемним питання залишається
улаштування внутрішніх шкільних туалетів
і це надзвичайно серйозна проблема яка
викликає посмішки лише хіба певних
представників засобів масової інформації
але тривожичі окремих регіонах
Рівненська Закарпатська
івано-франківська області близько
половини шкіл мають лише вуличні
зручності на засіданні уряду 15 серпня
місцевим органам влади надано доручення
протоколки обміну номер 62 вжити
відповідних заходів до облаштування
внутрішніх туалетів у загальноосвітніх
навчальних закладах в яких вони відсутні
відповідальні керівники цю роботу
розпочали раніше Так лише в Київській
області за цей один рік вдалося
облаштувати внутрішні вбиральні в 61
в середньому освітньому закладі найкращі
показники в Дніпропетровській області Я
вчора був присутній на обласній
педагогічній конференції за цей рік
коштами місцевих бюджетів і обласного
бюджету зроблено
облаштування внутрішніх вбирань 150
середніх школах і на сьогоднішній день в
трьох регіонах України в
Дніпропетровській Донецькій
Миколаївській областях ця проблема
вирішена наступне професійно-технічна
освіта з 1 вересня цього року
працюватиму 991 навчальний заклад
професійно-технічної освіти для навчання
розпочнуть понад 400 000 осіб в тому
числі близько 170 000 першокурсників дві
третини учнів одночасно з професією
будуть здобувати повну загальну середню
освіту Кожен другий за час навчання
отримає дві та більше професій що
підвищить мобільність випускників на
ринку праці на сьогодні 99% професі
технічних навчальних закладів
підготовлено до нового навчального року
вартість здійснених навчальними
закладами ремонтних робіт вже перевалила
за 60 мільйонів гривень проте ремонту
потребує ще близько 2000
навчально-виробничих приміщень птнз та
188 котел надзвичайно серйозною
проблемою залишається оплата про
втехучилищем за теплу воду
енергопостачання проблема дійсно кричуща
зараз наші працівники знаходяться в
міністерстві фінансів Я сподіваюсь що
при перегляді і коригуванні державного
бюджету наприкінці вересня
цього року цю проблему вдасться повною
мірою розв'язати мушу лише одне сказати
на 2012 рік Міністерство На жаль
затверджені видатки які складають 27%
від реальної потреби
професійно-технічних училищ і технікумів
також підтягнулись професійно-технічні
заклади в плані готовності і
покомплектуванню педагогічними кадрами
залишається вакантними лише 2%. серед
них найбільші вакансій майстрів
виробничий виробничого навчання так
гірші показники в Миколаївській області
майже
19%. в Києві та Севастополі 10%
звичайно на першому місці залишається
забезпечення якості професійно-технічної
освіти відповідно до потреби економіки і
діючий національний класифікатор України
включає близько 6000 робітничих професій
а підготовка кваліфікованих робітників
профтехучилища здійснюється за
520-ма професіями для 25 професій
затверджено державні стандарти
профтехосвіти до жовтня 2012 року ми
плануємо затвердити ще 41 новий
державний стандарт професійно-технічної
професійно-технічної освіти хотів би
сказати що загальні обсяги державного
замовлення по профтехосвіті майже 194
тисячі осіб
певною мірою ще не скрізь воно виконано
Але сподіваюсь що до 1 вересня ця
проблема буде також позитивно вирішення
позашкільна освіта на сьогодні в системі
позашкільної освіти функціонує понад
півтори тисячі мобільних навчальних
закладів державної та комунальної форми
власності та 630
дитячо-юнацьких спортивних шкіл
позашкільної освітою охоплено майже 1
млн 550 тисяч дітей або 40% школярів для
дітей працюють також 80 гуртків та
творчих об'єктів Проблемне питання
Незважаючи на всі заходи які вживаються
міністерством та місцевими органами
управління освітою батьківськими
громадами для отримання та збереження
діючої мережі позашкільних закладів
продовжується не поодинокі процеси
об'єднання оптимізації ліквідації
позашкільних закладів під виглядом
перепрофілювання та злиття так за
минулий рік за рішенням місцевих органів
влади мережа позашкільних закладів
скоротилася на 14 одиниць
5 закладів припинили роботу в
Харківській області три у Львівській по
два в Черкаській і Донецькій по одному в
Тернопільській та Херсонській областях
Міністерство продовжує боротьбу і
відповідний наступ за прийняття закону
за повернення до норми закону про
фінансування позашкільної освіти з
першого кошика і наостанок вища освіта
державне замовлення на підготовку
фахівців з вищою освітою в цьому році
зазнала значного збільшення так на
підготовку молодших спеціалістів понад
59 000 місць в минулому році 54,5
бакалаврів 103 майже з половиною тисячі
місць по бакалаврам це на
22,600 місць більше ніж минулого року
спеціалістів на 2000 більше 64 з лишнім
тисяч і магістрів майже 33,5 тисячі
державне замовлення що на 200 100 осіб
більше ніж минулого року хотів би
особливо підкреслити що державні
замовлення зазнала якісних змін
збільшення кількості місць відбулося на
підготовку за напрямками
інформатика обчислювала техніка і
технічними спеціальностями трохи більше
економіки і підприємництва організація
вступної кампанії важливо інновацією
цьогорічної компанії стала робота всіх
вищих навчальних закладів незалежно від
рівня акредитації та форми власності в
її в єдиній державній базі з питання
світу що забезпечило небачену прозорість
вступної кампанії і оперативність
отримання даних про перебіг прийому заяв
та унеможливого які зловживання всього
до єдиної державної бази було підключено
1078 вищих навчальних закладів та їх
структурних підрозділів за числом
поданих заяв цьогорічна компанія є
рекордною за всі роки Незалежності
України було подано 1 млн майже 950
тисяч заяв А загалом вступній кампанії
взяли участь понад 600 тисяч
абітурієнтів Ну я думаю що за 180 років
і 200 існування деякі університети такої
кількості бажаючих не бачили наприклад
до Київського національного університету
імені Тараса Шевченка виявила бажання
вступити майже 46 000 осіб Ну якщо взяти
що середній абітурієнт особливо не Кияни
та й Кияни також приходить до
приймальної комісії супроводі трьох і
більше родичів спостерігачів
симпатиків то я думаю що приймальна
комісія лише цього університету мала
приємність і складність в цьому році
поспілкуватися приблизно повністю з
населенням
цілого обласного центру впродовж одного
місяця в гостях у працівників
приймальної комісії університету
Шевченко побувала населення обласного
центру
за графіком триває підготовка вищих
навчальних закладів до роботи в
осінньо-зимовий період усі роботи
відбуваються відповідно графіку ремонт і
система опалення та котелень завершено
на понад 70% від 15 до 15 жовтня їх е-е
буде завершено
Шановні колеги перш за все дільники
регіональних управління освіти і науки
нам з вами треба буде ще доповідати
Уряду про організований початок
навчального року і ви знаєте правду
краще знати зараз тому оскільки є ще
кілька днів до початку навчального року
сподіваюсь що ми всі знаємо реальну
картину з правду і про неї не соромно
буде говорити інформацію з першого
питання Я завершив якщо будуть якісь
запитання будь ласка подавайте їх
письмовому вигляді і висвітлюйте в
виступах і зараз Давайте будемо без
перерви переходити відразу до розгляду
нашого найголовнішого змістовного
питання
Шановні колеги ще кілька днів і в
Україну прийде особливо свято 1 вересня
воно надзвичайно державне державницьке
сімейне і об'єднуюче воно об'єднує всіх
і на кілька днів стирає політичні
агітаційні і інші розбіжності чи готові
Ми сьогодні до старту нової української
школи Саме так нової бо з 1 вересня всі
майже 430 тисяч першокласників України
починають навчання за новими державними
стандартами і програмами ці події
передувала без перебільшення надскладна
і напружена праця за декілька останніх
років ми створили всі перемови для
справжнього далеко не косметично
реформування освітньої галузі
модернізації її змісту
ми усвідомлювали що за 10 років світ
небаченими темпами змінився тому
науковцям кращим вчителям-практикам
довелося напрацювати якісно нові
державні стандарти дошкільної початкової
базової та повної загальної середньої
освіти а потім програми та навчальні
плани за кожним абсолютно за кожним з
цих документів були численні дискусії
суперечки навіть інтелектуальні баталії
громадський захист з'їзди вчителів
конференції таке інше обговорення
проводилось не лише в столиці усіх без
винятко регіонах країни мета була лише
одна забезпечити нашим дітям якісну нову
українську освіту сучасну доступну
модернізовану і конкурентоспроможну
всього за два роки прискореного маршу
пройдено шлях від нового стандарту до
створення нових українських підручників